حتى لو كنت رئيساً لأقوى دولة في العالم
، فلا تحاول إغضاب القذافي
، فالعقيد لن يوقفه شيء إن غضب
، العقيد يريد اغتيال رئيس الولايات المتحدة
، لكن لمااااذا؟
والمخابرات الأمريكية CIA
تحذر قادتها، وتعلن حالة الطوارئ،
( فما الذي جرى حينها في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية؟)
قادة المخابرات الأمريكية يحذرون الحكومة
أن العقيد القذافي، يخطط لاغتيال الرئيس رونالد ريغن
بحسب وثائق الدولة الإيرلندية عام ١٩٨١
وأُرسلت مذكرة لوزارة الخارجية الأمريكية
تقول ..
إن عملاء الاستخبارات الأمريكية قد حددوا ١٧ معسكرا لتدريب المقاتلين
في ليبيا بما في ذلك( معسكر ١٧ أبريل)،
للتحضير للعمليات الدولية،
لتقوم الدنيا بهذا الخبر في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
وفي مذكراته قال رونالد ريغن الرئيس السابق لأمريكا،
بعد أيام قليلة من حادثة الخليج
، حصل رجال الأمن على معلومات سرية
تشير إلى أن القذافي نصح بعض رفاقه
بأنه كان ينوي اغتيالي.
لذا ، عدت لاستخدام سترتي الحديدية كلما خرجت في العلن"
. وبعد ذلك ، حصل رجال الأمن على ما اعتبروه معلومات
ذات مصداقية عالية
ليست أنا فقط ، بل (نائب الرئيس) جورج بوش وكاسبر واينبرغر
مستهدفين من قبل فرق الاغتيال الليبية
التي تم تهريبها إلى هذا البلد)
، بعد ذلك كان ريغن قد أطلق  فوجا من الطائرات
واستهدف منزل العقيد في العزيزية
لكن العقيد خرج يلوح بيديه،
ويقول ها أنا ذا فأين أنتم!!؟
وأضافت الاستخبارات أن القذافي ينوي إرهاب العالم بقواته
التي يدربها لينشرها في الدول التي يريد إخافتها،
وقبل ذلك تم إحباط عملية اغتيال للسفير الأمريكي
في إيطاليا بتدبير من علي حجاسي
وكان فردا في المخابرات الليبية
وهو ما جعل الCIA تقول إن الديبلوماسيين الأمريكيين
معرضون للخطر في كل مكان من طرف القذافي
، كما اتهموا ليبيا أيضا بمحاولة
اغتيال القائم بأعمال السفارة الأمريكية في باريس،
لكن الأمر الأكثر خطورة هو التهديد الحقيقي الذي تعرض
له الرئيس الأمريكي رونالد ريغن،
إذ لم تملك المخابرات حينها أي تفاصيل  أخرى عن العملية
متى وكيف ستنفذ ما جعلهم في حالة استنفار
، بانتظار ما الذي سيفعله العقيد،،،
جدير بالذكر  هنا أن الرئيس ريغن انتهى به الحال
مقتولا بالرصاص، لكنه كان قد نجى من محاولة اغتيال
نفذها جون هينكلي في مارس من عام ١٩٨١
وهو العام ذاته الذي وصلته فيه تهديدات العقيد القذافي،
وتقول التقارير أن العقيد خطط لاغتيال ريغن
بعد أن أمر هذا الأخير بإسقاط طائرتين لليبيا فوق البحر المتوسط
عام ١٩٨٠
العقيد لم يقبل بانتهاك سيادته
فعليك بالتفكير ألف مرة قبل المساس بشيء يملكه العقيد
حتى وإن كنت ترأس أقوى دولة وأقوى جيش في العالم، ،